hallo mein name hier wir spielen heute
ein spiel mit dem namen der wilde tier
geht schon fertig wird rechtzeitig durch
einfach mal auf linken es geht also
nicht dass man jeden drückt es geht
ich drück mal eins von vorwärts
rückwärts lebensrecht aber wir sehen
schon hier ahaus dort das hier den wir
[Musik]
hier sehen wunderbar toll aus wir können
hier nach links laufen da passiert gar
nicht wir können hier ein bisschen hoch
springen können wir unseren
es ist mein müll kaputt wir können die
forderungen laufen und müssen hier
überspringen hierbei ja mein baum und
hier den krebs
da kann ich ja gar nicht töten und ich
auf den trauschein euro kletterte
[Applaus]
da hat man auf der linken seite sitzen
einfach irgendwelche heulen den krebs
und verwandte und so die eindrücke sage
ich eine story auch mehr oder research
ich würde sagen sorry bin ja ein lieber
mensch im inneren doch irgendwo also
zurück jetzt auf die eins und beauty of
the way you go ich bin im gefängnis hier
kann ich jetzt wiederum laufen kann auch
meine bank darauf springen kann mir
rechte laufen kann links hoch laufen und
kann auch passiert hier noch irgendwas
nur wenige minuten später louis
ich wurde entlassen glaube ich ich laufe
dieser zurückgeht schon hier das jetzt
nicht mehr aus sondern ich weiß nicht ob
das hitler sein soll dass bin auf jeden
fall nicht mehr ich da vorne
der type 3 ghia marsch aber wir laufen
mal weiter hier rum also wir sehen schon
kredite laufen wir ein bisschen weiter
die strecke dann auch
das ist der krebs den ich getötet habe
[Musik]
ich mache einfach mal so und sage einem
sorry und schaue ob der emir reagiert
nee
nicht weiter hier vorne lange her da war
mir vorher schon laufen so ein bisschen
weiter dran vorbei die sache ist update
für ihn was passiert hier hinten lang
und hier sehen wir jetzt eine wie sie
heute den jetziger uv- gewinn not try
before the lincoln das heißt
ich will jetzt noch
meine damen und herren ich laufe hier
lang und hat jetzt der krebs und ich
muss irgendwie an den krebs vorbeikommen
ich kann ja sogar durch den durchlaufen
tatsächlich also wir warten jetzt mal
hier habe hier sind schon mehrere klebt
aber durch die können wir auch noch
einfach durchlaufen hier ist wieder so
ein anderer krebs da gehe ich jetzt
einmal so runter das heißt den ersten
krebs hier habe ich bei seite und jetzt
laufe ich durch die beiden trieb sie
durch als sehr weit sich aber noch als
sehr sehr schwierig einfach kein zu
töten die ihr vor dem recht gebäuden
auch einfach mal lang laufen jetzt hier
oben lang und wir sehen schon jetzt
wieder lernen und jetzt laufen die mich
wieder zu dem girlfriend das golf resort
wir laufen rein und
[Musik]
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal enter wenn
wieder am start screen und wen oder
spiel wo zu gern stuttgart kreiert ja
wenn wir jetzt wieder aufbrechen klicken
dann wiederkommen vorne und ich glaube
auch das scheißegal ob ich den ersten
titel bei spielsweise wenn ich noch den
weiten drauf bringe da kommt ihr die
polizei an und ich bin wahrscheinlich in
ihren jobs ja genau das ist wirklich das
komplette spiel wurde dieses spiel
zugesendet und gesagt hey du karosse
früher diese helmi sigg wenn reihe
gespielt jedes video formierte sehr
wichtig man hat irgendwie glaube ich
über eine millionen aufrufe deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich suche solche
kartenspiele und wenn die kohle wird
beschreibt die gerne in die kommentare
dazu vielleicht noch ein videochat ich
hoffe auf jeden fall gedacht okay du
bist das hört sich doch ganz cool an
ja das ist somit das größte spiel aller
zeiten
trotzdem würde ich an der stelle sagen
freunde wenn euch das video gefallen
würde ich mich sehr freuen
hier findet jetzt ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren das
heißt ihr verpasst keine videos mehr und
es ist sehr nice und free und i7 fanshop
eingeblendet und hier und da ist ein
anderes video also klick darauf